♪
>> ON THIS DAY, 75 YEARS
AGO, 10,000 MEN SHED THEIR
BLOOD AND THOUSANDS
SACRIFICED THEIR LIVES, OUR
DEBT TO YOU IS EVERLASTING.
TODAY WE EXPRESS OUR UNDYING
GRATITUDE.
THE SACRIFICE THAT THEY MADE
DID NOT JUST WIN A BATTLE.
IT DID NOT JUST WIN A WAR.
THOSE WHO FOUGHT HERE WANT A
FUTURE FOR OUR NATION.
THEY WON THE SURVIVAL OF OUR
CIVILIZATION.
>> Greg: IT'S THE 75TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY.
YOU SEE ALL THOSE VETS?
THEY MAY BE IN THEIR 90'S
BUT WE ARE IN THEIR DEBT.
THE LUCKY SURVIVORS OF THE
73,000 PLUS AMERICANS
LIBERATED EUROPE SPENT THEIR
LAST DAY ON THOSE BEACHES.
AS ALWAYS WE MUST REMIND
OURSELVES THAT THE LIVES WE
LEAD ARE BASED ON THE LIVES
OF OTHERS.
IF YOU ARE LIVING A
PROSPEROUS, PEACEFUL LIFE IN
AMERICA, THEY BUILT THAT
THAT INCLUDES OUR FREEDOM TO
PURSUE HAPPINESS AND
ESPECIALLY THE GOD-GIVEN
RIGHT TO BE STUPID AND
SELF-OBSESSED.
WE OWE THAT TO THEM, TOO.
THE LEISURE TIME AND
CAREFREE EXISTENCE THAT
ALLOWS US TO BE SHALLOW THAT
WAS MADE POSSIBLE BY BOYS
WHO NEVER SAW WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED.
BOYS WHO NEVER DATED, NEVER
MARRIED BECAUSE THEY NEVER
HAD A FIRST KISS OR FOUND A
GIRLFRIEND.
THEY WERE NEVER LIKED ON
FACEBOOK OR SHAMED ON
TWITTER.
THEIR LIFE EXPERIENCES ENDED
SO YOURS COULD BEGIN.
SO WHAT HAVE YOU DONE WITH
IT?
HAVE YOU SAFERRED THAT GIFT
OR WASTED IT?
IN THE LIVES SINCE THEIRS,
WE SEE PEOPLE ADDRESSING THE
FAULTS OF THOSE FROM THE
PAST.
WE ARE THE ENLIGHTENED
GENERATION, SHEDDING THE
SINS OF THOSE WHO CAME
BEFORE US.
WE, THE YOUNG, SUPERIOR AND
OPEN-MINDED SCOFF AT THE
OLD, FRAIL AND INFIRM.
DO THEY KNOW ABOUT OUR
WRETCHED PAST?
AND IF THEY DO, WHY HAVEN'T
THEY DONE ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
TURNS OUT THEY ALREADY DID A
LOT.
THEY FACED REAL AGGRESSIONS.
SO OTHERS COULD COMPLAIN
ABOUT MICROAGGRESSIONS.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU SEE IT
FROM THE BEACH IN NORMANDY
75 YEARS AGO, A PLACE THAT
WAS NOBODY'S IDEA OF A SAFE
SPACE.
I REALLY ENJOYED THAT THERE
WAS ONE MOMENT TODAY
FEATURING A 93-YEAR-OLD
VERNAL FLIRTING WITH THE
FIRST LADY.
I JUST CAN'T GET TIRED OF
THIS.
>> HELLO, HOW ARE YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU HOPE
THAT AT THAT AGE YOU WILL
STILL BE FLIRTING WITH --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: SO MUCH FOR PICNICS
AT THE GUTFELDS.
IF I COME OVER AND START
FLIRTING WITH YOUR WIFE.
I THINK YOU WILL PUNCH ME
OUT.
BUT, THE PRESIDENT WAS QUITE
PRESIDENTIAL IN THAT MOMENT.
QUITE DEFERENTIAL TO THE
VET.
AND I THINK HE WAS QUITE
GOOD IN HIS SPEECH.
I THOUGHT IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE MOMENTS, JESSE WAS
JUST JOKING WITH ME THAT HE
HAD THE PRESIDENTIAL VOICE.
>> HE SURE DID.
>> HE WAS ON THE THE
TELEPROMPTER AND HE WAS ON
MESSAGE.
THERE WAS EVEN PEOPLE HERE
AT FOX MAKING FUN OF SOME OF
OUR RIVALS AT THE OTHER
NETWORKS BECAUSE THEY, TOO
WERE PRAISING THE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS PRESENTATION TODAY.
ONE THING THAT STRUCK ME,
GREG, AS MUCH AS YOU LIKE
THE OLD GUY FLIRTING.
I WAS JUST AT THE FACT THAT
THIS 75TH ANSWER ANNIVERSARY
WILL BE THE LAST ONE FOR SO
MANY OF THE SURVIVORS
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THEIR
90'S.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
THE 100TH, SO I THINK THIS
IS A VERY SPECIAL MOMENT FOR
THEM AND YOU KNOW, I JUST --
YOU KNOW, IF THERE WAS ONE
THING THAT I WOULD SAY, I
JUST WISH TRUMP HAD STAYED
ON MESSAGE AND STAYED IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL VOICE.
I JUST DIDN'T LIKE THE --
YOU KNOW, TAKING SHOTS AT
SCHUMER, NANCY.
I JUST THINK IT WASN'T
NECESSARY.
>> YOU ARE ASKING A LITTLE
BIT TOO MUCH, JUAN.
>> Greg: TO JUAN'S POINT
EVERY YEAR A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY LEAVES THE PLANET.
WHAT DO WE REPLACE IT WITH?
WHAT DO WE DO TO MAKE SURE
THOSE STORIES.
>> Katie: THAT'S THE BIG
QUESTION.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
REPEATING THE STORIES AND
TALKING ABOUT WHO THESE
PEOPLE WERE.
AND I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
D-DAY AND OVERALL YOU LOOK
AT WORLD WAR II.
YOU REFLECT ON YOUR OWN
FAMILY AND YOU ARE PROUD OF
YOUR OWN HISTORY OF YOUR
FAMILY.
MY GRANDFATHER FOUGHT IN
WORLD WAR II IN THE PACIFIC
AND ACTUALLY MET MY
GRANDMOTHER IN AUSTRALIA
AFTER HE GOT MALARIA AND WAS
IN THE HOSPITAL.
HEARD HER THERE AND CAME
BACK TO THE STATES.
SHE WAITED IN ARIZONA FOR
HIM TO COME BACK FROM THE
WAR.
>> THANK GOD FOR MALARIA.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S THE
ONLY TIME YOU WILL EVER HEAR
THAT STATEMENT.
IN TERMS OF PAYING IT
FORWARD IT'S INTERESTING TO
SEAT PEOPLE SHARING THE
STORY OF D-DAY TODAY AND
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
YOU LOOK AT THE HUMANITY OF
THE PEOPLE THAT DAY WHO KNEW
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO GET
OUT ALIVE AND LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT THERE IS NOT THAT
MANY OF THESE VETERANS LEFT.
IT JUST REMINDS YOU OF YOU
WHO QUICK LIFE IS.
BUT THE SACRIFICES THAT THEY
MADE FOR OUR FREEDOM AND FOR
THE FREEDOM OF FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
THEY KNEW IT GOING IN THAT
DAY WHETHER THEY WERE GOING
TO MAKE IT OUT OR NOT.
>> Greg: YOU COULD SAY THEY
FOUGHT A WORLD WAR FOR
WATERS WORLD TO EXIST.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS MY
FAVORITE MONOLOGUE THEY
FOUGHT AGGRESSION SO YOU
COULD FIGHT MICROAGGRESSION
DON'T LET THAT GET TO YOUR
HEAD.
>> Greg: I HAVE A MICROHEAD.
>> Jesse: THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE WARS WHERE YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO SEE THIS AGAIN FOR
AMERICA BECAUSE OF THE
ADVANCEMENT IN MILITARY
MODERNIZATION AND
TECHNOLOGY.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO SEE A
MASS CASUALTY INCIDENTS
HAPPEN LIKE THAT SO QUICKLY
JUST BREACH AGO BEACH IT WAS
LIKE A MEAT GRINDER THEY
ADVANCE AND SO COURAGEOUS.
BECAUSE OF THAT SACRIFICE,
LIKE YOU SAID, WE CAN FALL
OFF A CLIFF TAKING SELFIES.
THE MEDIA CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT
A DINNER.
THE SO TRIVIAL AND KIND OF
PUTS THINGS INTO
PERSPECTIVE.
ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE
STARTED TO DO WITH MY
DAUGHTERS WHO ARE 7 IS
WHENEVER WE SEE A VETERAN AT
THAT AGE, YOU KNOW, 90 YEARS
OLD.
HE HAS THE HAT ON IF IT'S IN
A PARADE OR OUT ON THE
BOARDWALK OR SOMETHING WE
WILL GO UP AND JUST SHAKE
HIS HAND AND SAY THANK YOU.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR HIM
TO HEAR BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SACRIFICE.
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
THE YOUNGER GENERATION TO
THOUGHTFULLY AND
RESPECTFULLY SAY THANK YOU
TO THAT GENERATION AS WELL
BECAUSE THE GREATEST
GENERATION ENABLED
GENERATIONS OF AMERICANS TO
PROSPER.
>> Greg: JESSE'S POINT IS
YOU MAY NEVER SEE THAT
AGAIN.
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD THING
THE WAY WE FIGHT WARS.
DO YOU THINK WE WOULD STILL
KEEP A SECRET LIKE THAT?
I MEAN OPERATION OVERLOAD
WAS BASED ON DECEPTION.
>> Dana: DID YOU READ I
THINK IT WAS JUST RELEASED
LETTER THAT GENERAL
EISENHOWER RELEASED TO HIS
WIFE.
SIX THINGS HAPPENING AND HAD
TO BE VERY VAGUE ABOUT IT OF
COURSE IT'S NOT IN AN EMAIL
IT'S IN CODED LANGUAGE
BECAUSE IT WAS A SNAIL MAIL
OPERATION.
I THINK SOME OF THE WEAPONS
WE FACE NOW ARE POSSIBLY
MORE DEADLY.
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF MARRYING UP A BIOTERROR
AGENT WITH SOME SORT OF
DEVICE.
THAT IS -- THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH.
WHAT THIS JENNINGS ALSO DID
IS THEY WENT TO LIBERATE.
BUT ALSO TO CONQUER AN IDEA.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Dana: BECAUSE THEY
CONQUERED THAT IDEA WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO LIVE IN PEACE
AND PROSPERITY.
ONE OF THE WAYS WE HAVE TO
HONOR THEIR LEGACY IS BY
CONTINUING IT.
LIKE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE -- WE
IN AMERICA AND I THINK
JOINED BY 50 OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE SUPPORTING THE RIGHT
SIDE IN VENEZUELA.
WE HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A
HORRIBLE DICTATOR IN SUDAN
WHO HAS BEEN BASICALLY
VIOLENTLY GOING AFTER CIVIL
PROTESTERS DOWN THERE.
THERE ARE THINGS HAPPENING
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
HUMAN RIGHTS, ET CETERA.
I KNOW THAT WE CAN'T DO
EVERYTHING.